Oh
I think that being attracted to a
certain kind of incredibly smart
charming accomplished but also dangerous
and emotionally unavailable man was one
of my emos I also had a huge weakness
for full court press seduction okay
because it was speedy it was also
fantastical I think it fit into the
whole artist trip you know whether it
was let me whisk you off your feed and
the intent the instant intensity love at
first sight thinking that that was
something that was true so there's also
a way that these kinds of relationships
will address a depression an underlying
depression that I've certainly been
diagnosed with many times I've never
taken any drugs for it and I thought I
just have to work harder at it but above
but I was obviously medicating myself
with these kinds of relationships
because when you get that instant hit
where there's fear because they're on a
vote unavailable emotionally or in
whatever other way you get that fear
pleasure those are I believe the most
powerful circuits in the brain if you
get them both activated stimulate the
same time someone who has a normal
background would be a danger danger
they'd run but me you know some like me
I feel alive finally and it's like a
jolt of electricity and think
Frankenstein's bride or something really
it's like love as the perfect reanimator
the main thing is that as a love addict
I was always looking outside myself for
someone to complete me what is that
platonic story that originally we were
two people fused into a ball that would
kind of roll around right and then there
was this rupture we'd split apart we
spend the rest of our time looking for
our other half okay so I think that in
my case it was about not taking
responsibility for fulfilling my own
life so I think that's at the root of
the settling as well if you're not
comfortable with yourself and satisfied
with yourself and what you're doing
there's going to be something suspect
and what you're open to and if you're
seeking already I mean in my case I
spent all my time seeking the one the
mythical one who would completely and
frankly who would address the weaknesses
that I wasn't addressing whether it was
creative because that's another thing
you know addictive energy is creative
energy and addiction can also be seen as
avoiding creative responsibility
you